it's somewhere between this one or two
that'd be great okay
so I want to make this or narrow this
down right so here's whether the name of
this come here if I take this interval
this interval here I know the route has
to be somewhere in here and if I have it
if I by sector 0.5 or what enough 302 if
I now test again right and in fact I
literally I'm going to practice testing
if I test again and see what this
function is doing it at 1 1 and a half
I'm going to get something that's like
this either negative or positive right
now I've already done this one so this
looks to be like normal 3 or 2 square is
Dinah 4 and then you take away 3 which i
think is negative 3/4 now the value of
it is not so important to me what really
matters is the sign right so you can see
here right if this there's like negative
1 so negative 3/4 not quite that far
away so about this now you can see I'm
starting to be near trying to head in
where the bridges now I can ignore this
part here it's not young its name
right there it has to be somewhere where
the change in sign of codes okay so I've
narrowed my search I'm gonna narrow yeah
I'm gonna hover another time so I'm
gonna say okay well what's halfway
between 1 and 1/2 and 2
1.75 1 and 3/4 up to it
so now that I can't eat all I want to
find out what the function is doing
there so I'm going to say F of one and
three point someone want to give me a
value gives me as a decimal
well whatever remember again I'm not
that interesting value what I'm really
interested in is the scien what do you
get zero point
so what anyone
whatever 16 just wants to think I'll
just do that that's one we can stay a
fraction then we're not gonna last very
long
and that's again one on 16 okay so where
is that why don't you put it
well it's above is it positive it's not
very far away why don't you say that's 1
so that's 1/2 that's about there ok so
you can see now again I've narrowed in
further I've had the interval from
what's now I've done it twice okay so
now I'm in here I could stop if I wanted
to all I'm going to do is I'm gonna keep
on doing it until I miss accurate and I
want to be right
remember when I say engineers when we
need a certain little accuracy at some
point it gets ridiculous the hundredth
decimal place no one can tell right so
here I'm still between 1.5 0.75 it's
still a bit of rain so now just to speed
things up a little bit I've already gone
through this process so rather than
making McKenney because I'll show you
the results but I thought so the next
hobby of the interval between P and P
are pretty sure is one of five names and
the value I got for that was this so I'm
going to take this right I'm gonna come
out of it to make that I'm gonna say
right well I have the interval so I'm
here
and the ballot I got was just negative
so it's about there so this is one and
five
it's so I just need to get closer in
question for some the next one is going
to be one and eleven sixteenths and the
decimal I got for that was
okay now like I said I can just keep on
going
however fine one my graph you're
starting to get a bit difficult so I'm
are 'but rarely going to stop at the
moment the question will generally say
give it to me this many times will give
me a desired accuracy them give it to me
for example to the nearest one decimal
place or two decimal places if you get
your calculator out now and I can see I
must be in am I'm gonna get this color I
must be in here right can you see that
what is one and eleven sixteenths what
is that actual decimal value
1.68 this is he's not a success
okay and what is our upper one that's
one of three coins we know that is
that's 1.75 so now I know right that you
can see on my graph right I must be in
that blue interval
somewhere right three three has to be
between these so I'm gonna say this
looks me I'm going to say root three
must be bounded I've got a lower bound
and I don't know where it is but it's in
there somewhere right
so root 3 is between these now I want to
actually know what's the decimal value
so rather than say a range because this
is where I'm going to stop and welcome
to anymore calculations I'm going to say
my best guess is it's in the middle and
that's my best guess if I had to say I
know it's gotta be here and here I'm
just going to arbitrarily pick women I
don't know which it's gonna lean one way
or the other
like for example you can it's hard to
get to depends on the function you might
have thought okay I've got a low down
Kia and a high up you can see well this
is this is x squared minus three right
so we should know actually how this
behavior I'm gonna get minus three he's
gonna be my vertex and it's gonna come
up like this this is a problem okay so
I'm not surprised that it's further this
way than that way but I'm just gonna
guess now that I'm this close halfway in
between so what is halfway between these
two guys can someone average it for me
to sit on point seven two
now if you calculate in there you can
verify victory is in fact what win 7/3
okay so that was pretty close and have a
look at like was this complicated maths
and don't know I just had to evaluate
some numbers with a little bit laborious
that's because it's a very simplistic
way of doing it no fancy you like
identities treat an almond tree or
calculus involved so the maths was easy
but it sort of converged there a little
slow I would say this gives us the
answer to the nearest one doesn't place
the second decimal places brought but
it's pretty close available